[Music]
what up anime fans today we're here to
talk about episode 77 of dragon ball
super ant-man the first in the
tournament survival arc which is which I
can't believe finally here so excited so
there's been a lot of work around the
live stream today and then also the
editing for the blue Geass video which
we already released and then now it's
finally time for drying Ball super so
yeah like three videos made in one day
crazy anyways this has been pretty
pretty cool experiencing this new arc
and the intro itself was awesome I enjoy
the new animation I enjoy the new song
and I love the fact that now we're going
to see more of Android 17 because I was
always wondering like you know what I
was I was surprised because we never
mentioned him so now seeing him
hopefully elaborating on his story his
character is going to be interesting
there's also then the fact that master
roshi looks like a total badass in the
intro and there's the fact that Gohan
seems like he's powering up to unlocking
elder Kai's potential which kind of
seems like he might be getting back into
things back into shape I hope so I
really miss like rest in peace teen
gohan
I miss you man but we'll see maybe we'll
see a resurrection of bad epicness the
devil Sandman in the intro which was
which was reassuring to say the least so
we open up with this episode with the
vanos the two of them and they seem to
be playing marbles with wait for it
planets so they were pretty much hitting
planets into one another and I don't
know it just didn't seem to be just
simulation because later it jumped into
actual real size planets getting
destroyed so it seems like they're just
destroying planets for fun and they're
even bored with it but they're still
doing it which is pretty problematic if
since you're like the king of the
universe and everything but that aside
it definitely showed the power of these
these two individuals these two guys and
wow it's crazy it i mean these guys are
way more powerful than we and yet more
naive than Goku and that's saying a lot
and super so we definitely got to watch
out for them and I mean who knows they
might reluctantly become the enemies in
this new arc and then we get the goku
and then we get to some funny hilarious
slice of life moments in this Dragon
Ball super episode including these
bandits trying to stick up Goku which
was hilarious like Goku worst possible
person you could stick up they pretty
much try to take the truck the new truck
that Beaumont got him he's like on no
way he beat them up of course without
breaking a sweat but then one shot
actually ends up hitting his skin and
usually like that wouldn't mean anything
but this time he actually got a little
little the tiniest scratch after
blocking all those bullets and I mean
who says that Superman has got anything
on Goku no way no way goku's on top of
that [ __ ] doesn't even need to transform
super saiyan just saying you got a
scratch from a bullet that's not even
usually the case you wouldn't usually do
it but since he's apparently been out of
practice so that's why he's actually
gotten a scratch from the bullet so
reminds us of the Crillon getting
injured with a bullet so it looks like
sands are beyond that either if they
don't train so obviously we're going
back to training and that's great and
there's a lot of other hilarious moments
in this episode after he realizes that
no one really wants to train including
Crillon who's actually you know busy
doing his job then we actually have goku
contacting weeks and of course how do
you get wheat or beers do whatever you
want get them food that they haven't
tried before which is weird that they
would have to not try it since
apparently they love everything so you
think they just enjoy the food they
already know they love but I guess you
got a guy do new stuff so I'm hoping
they all run out any time soon so we
obviously is down he picks up Goku picks
up Goten at his house goten wants to go
train with him so he sneaks away with
Goten even though she she wants him to
study cuz you know look at the Wonder
two did for Gohan I mean he's definitely
doing great right but anyways we've done
a lot of funny moments including when
Goten tells Goku gives them a lecture
practically about how to be polite which
was hilarious he teaches them about
proper manners Go Go Achmed you know a
lot so yeah nice Goku now even goats and
surpass you and just overall knowledge
excellent anyways Bulma ends with catch
and Goten before he actually goes to
wheezes planet which is a shame because
I'd like to see it goes on really as he
gets add training and dis aged it also
love for it I feel like that could be
interesting to pursue but then again she
she's not gonna let that happen they
have to study these scholars also what
do you know bull most pregnant so a lot
of us knew already that this would be
the case but yeah bull most pregnant and
we'll see this is very interesting it's
going to be boy girl can we get clues
from GT or that out of the bag it's
going to be interesting to see how that
character develops and are we going to
even have time while the show is still
going on to develop this young character
that's going to be definitely
interesting and I think the best part of
that whole situation
just seeing vegeta's response to it
because magida did not want to go train
so we'd see like a complete 180 in
Regina like this is meaningful guys
we've seen Vegeta go from everything
being about being the best fighter
beating Kakarot and this time he says no
cheese Dom boma wouldn't like it I
should stay for the kid being born and
go qui even teased that means even like
come on with jada like you want me to be
stronger than you Isaac will see kakarot
bomb not leaving so that was big guys
the cheetah is definitely now completely
different person than he was and it's
cool to see how much he's you know
changed and how much he cares for boma
and his son or daughter to be that's
going to be interesting i look forward
to seeing his further evolution of the
father I mean wow this is the same guy
who attacked earth and then gave in to
his hate again for majin vegeta now you
he's better than Goku as goku said he
was bad one goat son was born so you
gotta love you gotta love how far she
has come and then we see goku
remembering about the tournament of
course it's going to be the main event
of this whole arc and obviously he
ignores Bews and wheezes very
intelligent and justified warning not to
push the button and go see the xenos
because obviously there's going to be
problems and go who doesn't want to
listen he pushes it you go see those nos
and your minds of the tournament and of
course we find out in the preview that
the universe's that do poorly are going
to be erased so literally Goku by being
his naive self who just loves to fight
put the whole his universe as well other
universes in danger which is obviously
very problematic and this is like the
hero of the universe's usually and now
he put everyone he loves including other
strangers in danger so yeah I mean why
why but for our sakes it's going to be
interesting and I guess the create
thinking how do we make this interesting
I mean what's what's the kick how to
make it more intense and they're like ah
let's just put the universe is on the
line yeah don't worry cool man now we
have the universe's are gonna be on the
line go who better step up and get his
game he's the reason for all this and I
hope that they're gonna figure out a
solution I think they will wear No
universities are destroyed because once
they determine success or whatever but
yeah it goes again to show goku's how
naive he is and also again we see the
xenos are really good people they're
neutral but in order to satisfy their
own boredom they're willing to cause
mass destruction to all universes which
is pretty problematic and I mean again
when you have someone the most powerful
character pretty much gone of gods and
then they're as naive and don't really
care about consequences as these guys
are you're definitely gonna see some
problems so I look forward to seeing how
that progresses and how they the
characters deal with these denims
another thing that's revealed is how old
the universe is which is interesting so
apparently the universe is three billion
135 million five hundred thousand and
six hundred and three days old so that
would roughly translates in our logic
obviously not using earth logic but
anyways I would translate to about eight
million five hundred and ninety thousand
four hundred and thirteen years but they
also say on the 157th hour as we know we
have 24 hours so it's much longer than
that even seems the bad thing is huge so
we get a sense for how long these denos
if they don't change positions have been
here and how long the universe has been
here insane to even think about and yeah
guys like nice so far i love the
animation for this season and now we're
approaching everything has been set the
stage that's set and now we're waiting
to see some awesome battles and you know
that even the smaller characters like
Master Roshi I got to put up some
entertaining fights hey guys if you want
to keep up with these reviews subscribe
every saturday i'll be doing a review of
the episode so look forward to that
until next time see you space cowboys
you
[Applause]
[Music]